este es el rosedal de palermo uno de los
parques más populares de la ciudad de
buenos aires todos los años muchas
personas vienen a celebrar aquí
especialmente el 21 de septiembre el día
de la primavera pero este es un año
especial porque finalmente después de
muchos meses de pandemia en las últimas
semanas comenzaron a descender
sostenidamente los casos los
fallecimientos por kobe 19 y también la
cantidad de gente internada en terapias
intensivas así que este 21 de septiembre
este día de la primavera es
particularmente especial yo en mi caso
personal pasé por el cobista así que es
como que es un renacer digamos es
disfrutar más que nunca en el día no con
los amigos y demás se me pone muy feliz
poder salir tranquila y ya con vacuna y
todo es mucho mejor más cómodo se siente
salir sin miedos
mucha alegría pero también mucha
responsabilidad porque todos
no pasó lo del virus pero bueno los
chicos necesitan salir necesitan
disfrutar de un día por lo menos después
de tanto de un año y medio de
restricciones este optimismo coincide
este mismo 21 de septiembre con el
anuncio por parte del gobierno de un
progresivo relajamiento de las medidas
restrictivas vinculadas con el coi 19 y
así aparece entonces la esperanza de que
tal vez argentina se esté acercando a la
posibilidad de dejar atrás esta pandemia